they killed her and the baby
even to this day it still hurts so I
left her there
with that baby and they never got out of
there which does make me realize that I
was the next victim
[Music]
shall we kind of start from you telling
me about your childhood what was it like
I had an amazing childhood
unfortunately my dad passed away when I
was 14 which led me to I didn't
understand was grieving procedure
um which led me to leave home at the age
of 16. I just wanted to go and be my own
person I've always been a bit of a funny
individual and I thought it was a bit of
an adventure to become an adult
it was around about October of
1976. I had a boyfriend at the time and
his parents had a spare hay so I went to
stay there
um and then that led me into meeting up
with Anne-Marie who I'd been at school
with who actually told me that her
parents had a flat going
and from there on I went to meet Fred
and Rose
look at the flight and be accepted to
the flight I moved in within the week
talking about the 25 Cromwell Street
what was your room what was the house
what what did it all look like
um yeah you go in the front door and to
the left-hand side was Rosie's room
um to the right hand side was the family
living room which was always very clean
very tidy almost surgical
um and then through the living room was
the kitchen out the kitchen was the back
Garden
um there was a set of stairs as you went
in and I was two flights up I was the
top of the house at the front
and my room was just a room with what I
needed in it in between my room was to
the right there was room on the left
with another couple in and there was a
little kitchenette in between us
what was your first impression on Frozen
Fred
and Rose were besotted with each other
absolutely besotted with each other and
it showed Rose was always a little bit
aloof but Fred was a true gentleman
very friendly
um a very good landlord
um I didn't see very much of the family
life because
unless you were invited you never went
into the family area which you know
which is right
um when I used to babysit the children
it used to be
a little bit of playing time and then
straight to bed so there was never
really because they were a lot younger
they wouldn't really have had
conversations in that respect anyway
um but I never heard anything negative
from the children
once I eventually was asked to go
through and sometimes I go through to
the kitchen to take my washing through
um I'd I'd see Rose having a go at
Anne-Marie mostly
um because it seemed Ann Marie had to
get the children ready in the morning
for school and
you don't give them a piece of toast
without water so she was quite sort of
full on with with Anne-Marie
um it seemed like
they were unmarie's children not roses I
thought it was a bit over the top
but then every every family is brought
up differently
I basically kept myself to myself and so
I had a boyfriend so he'd come and see
me often and my siblings came to see me
um I'd only see the children when they
were going in or out of the house or
unless I was asked to look after them
and I just see if there are any problems
with the room I'd say to Fred
um
and I'd see him then or just see him
walking around the house but very rarely
saw Rose
because she kept herself to herself
I just happened to be in the living room
one night slept with him watching a
movie I can't remember why
and Fred was in the kitchen doing
something and the doorbell went
on a red light litter
and I just remember saying oh my
goodness it's like the red light area
and I was just oh shh
mum has her friends in there and we're
not allowed to go in
did you ever see any reaction from Fred
Turtle did it seem to bother him
no he just carried on what he was doing
they never argued
they were they seem to be the perfect
couple
do you think there was a moment where
you got an impression that something
might not be right in the house did you
get any hints
yeah it was the reason I left was
because I'd heard Heather
screaming in the middle of the night
stop it Daddy stop it
um several nights in a row I heard the
same thing
I couldn't father make what it was but
it didn't sound good whether she was
having nightmares or not but I did ask
and a member of the family
said
is what he does he feels is his right to
break his daughters in
I kept playing it back in my mind what
could I do but I don't think I could
have done anything different because I
was a runaway
um nobody was going to believe me if I
went and told anybody so my best
defense was get out
because I couldn't be a part of whoever
was going on so
I arranged to move out and didn't tell
them until the day I was moving out
hold was Heather the at that at the time
of that incident
I remember right she was about eight
so obviously now we kind of when we know
we know about Rose and Fred we for
example know that a lot of things happen
in the cellar have you ever been there
yes
Fred said to me one day come on have a
look at what I've done for the children
so okay
he took me into the cellar which was
very dark very dank
uh he'd painted bits on the walls he'd
put a little bed in there he'd put a
little box of toys in there but I'm
claustrophobic so I immediately said to
him this is very nice but I need to get
out of here
and I was in there probably five minutes
talks just looking at it and praised him
up for what he'd done for the children
I'm gonna ask a question you don't have
to answer but we now know that among
other things Fred raped and kind of
forced into prostitution uh Anne-Marie
I can honestly say I was never aware of
it
I just thought she was out with her
friends and she wasn't in the house it
was never made aware of that
so can you talk me through you moving
out of the house when after after what
you've heard and what you've seen I just
made the decision that I I didn't really
want to be there with those
circumstances I find an alternative
place to live
but something made me not tell them that
I was moving out until the day I moved
out which was the day that I would
normally pay the rent and I just said to
them I'm moving out they went oh when I
went now because I'd already removed all
but one bag full of stuff anyway
and I just walked away
what was their reaction to rosenfreude
shock
um you kind of said are you sure you
really want to move out yes yes I find
somewhere else to live and I need to
move out
did they ever try to stop you no
I think had I told them that I was
moving out before I moved out
I actually don't think I would have got
out of there
you mentioned surely what was she like
she became my best friend so when you
moved in she was already pregnant yes
did you know anything about the father
of the child
eventually she told me that it was Fred
but I disbelieved her
um because I thought yeah yeah she's
just yeah the landlord's my boyfriend I
just thought she was being a bit of a
girl
how old was she
she was just a little bit older than
myself
so like 17. uh she I think she was
nearer to 18.
um
yeah we were good we had plans uh when
she'd had the baby
she was going to get a flat and we were
going to meet for coffee uh yeah we were
very good friends she was a lovely
person
did you stay in touch with any of the
children after moving out I went back to
see if surely had the baby and if Rose
had the baby because they would both do
pretty much the same time
Shirley had gone and they said she'd
left which confused me a little bit
because we were meant to stay in touch
um but I went to see them and I went and
had a coffee and saw Rosie's baby which
kind of shocked me a little bit because
it wasn't
quite baby
I didn't realize at the time and just
had a general Child bed my goodbyes and
went
do you still think about it a lot a lot
you feel but I
I feel that had I had the guts to tell
somebody I don't think the outcome would
have been any different
but what I think about is that Heather
was innocent
and I left and I left Shirley there and
she never got out of it
so I happened to show
they killed her and the baby
even to this day it still hurts I left
her there
with that baby and they never got out of
there which does make me realize that I
was the next victim
at what point did you find out what
happened to Shirley
so
it wouldn't be good 20 odd years after
I'd left
because I
I cut that side of my life off
um and just forgot all about it and
until the news came out that Heather's
body had been found or
I'd forgot all about it not forgotten
all about I'd locked it all away because
it was a part of my life that I didn't
need to think about every day
um as it broke on the news
it horrified me even more because of the
room that they found the one behind the
chimney breast was my room
and the one that they found under the
bath was where I bathed
so when you found out about the scale of
the things that were happening in the
house how did it make you feel
devastated
heartbroken for all those that have been
lost
and angry
because I then started to date my
thoughts about what could I have done
but I still came to the same conclusion
oh
I couldn't have done anything different
nobody would believe me
there's no different answer
Fred and Rose were arrested in 1994.
and then as they were waiting the trials
had committed suicide and it was only
Rose left to present in court
how did it make you feel
I'm angry that he'd taken his own life
to get away from
what was happening
uh I'd say Rose was the domineering one
and the last time they crossed paths
when they were going in night of course
she shunned him and I believe he
couldn't take it
when you saw rose on trial what did you
think of her
I hated her hated her for what she'd
done for what they'd done and I can
honestly say I stood in that Dock and I
stared her out
my fret Fred had done this before he met
Rose and Rose had done it on her own and
then they carried on to do it together
so they were both as guilty as one
another
how was your life after Rose went to
prison
for a little while I was a little bit
um
I wouldn't say traumatized but I was a
little bit
confused over what they'd done how it
happened could I have spotted anything I
racked my brain could I even though the
sentence had been served it still made
you think about could you did you
but the more and more I thought about it
the more and more I realized I didn't
have any signs there was nothing I could
have done
so I then did my normal shut it into
another little box in my head and forgot
all about it and got on with my family
life
but you still cut this
quite I mean quite disturbing
information to yourself for quite a few
years how did that feel I kept it to
myself because
it was something that was a part of my
younger days
and as I said I didn't know what I could
do about it so it was just best to walk
away from it and just lock it back in
but I still do ask the same question and
I still do think about
maybe if I had or could I say surely
could have saved Heather
but then I still come to the same
conclusion and lock it back in again
to look back at these events how does it
feel it feels like
um
even though it was real is not real it's
a part of my history
the only way affected me was slightly of
a mental version when it all came out
but the fact that the person
part of this
team as I would call them has been dealt
with
that's another one off the streets
how do you feel about the fact that the
house was demolished
ecstatic
because it should never be left there
what they've done is amazing it's narrow
remembrance Gardens and it's beautiful
I've been to see you I was going to ask
if you've been there
how was that
it was it was
a bit daunting because I knew that's
where it had taken place but because
they've made it so lovely it was
absolutely lovely to go and see and the
thought that they've remembered all
those that were lost
do you think it made you feel a bit
better about Shirley and her memory
slightly I'll never feel aware about her
[Music]
and as I walked faster I could hear his
footsteps getting faster and faster and
then sheer Panic took over
and I started to run towards the end of
the road and as I ran I could feel his
his steps getting nearer and nearer and
nearer so close behind me